Carleton Spears from Battersea Dogs hope
joins us now with a very special friend
this is a Merry Christmas thank you
how beautiful is he is he a rescue dog
he's a rescue dog sir he's from
Battersea as well and I got he came in
as a stray and I got him when he was
about it was about three months old
I was I was thinking about getting a dog
by thought Edwards got to be the one ya
know he's obviously retriever it could
be yeah there could be something else
there possibly setter and he's quite you
know he is quite slim for a golden
retriever despite the fact that he
absolutely adores food and would eat
forever
but I'm quite careful about that but
he's um he's got quite a fast metabolism
so he does so obviously he's even today
because lots of people get puppies for
Christmas never a good idea it's not a
good idea and we do try to sort of get
that message home as often as we can and
we do often see kind of a surge it tends
to be more around sort of march-april
time so I think people get the dogs you
know get puppies at Christmas and then
perhaps when they the novelty wears off
all the dogs get a little bit bigger
that's when you know they tend to
unfortunately give me that face very
well dysentery he does I think he
spotted the produce a little bit food
I'm hoping he doesn't really know silly
ya know it's already gone so what
happens people bring the dogs to
Battersea or I think did they get left
out so because I saw in the paper just
this week that you had eight puppies
talk to you we did were those luckily
those puppies were that they came in as
a gift so the owners brought them into
it they were an unwanted litter but
unfortunately sometimes you know people
do dump dogs we've had dogs dumped in
you know boxes outside tied to lampposts
all sorts of things or indeed of course
pink dog sometimes our strays and we can
try and reunite boys he's very taken he
loves people yeah that'd be two people
who I think that advice anytime you hear
really not just Christmas I mean at any
time
it's obviously there's lots and lots of
things to think about there's the space
issue the time issue all these different
things the commitment of love and you
know you need to exercise the dog two or
three times every day and you've got to
think about the expense of food yeah
medical veterinary treatment all those
different things that you have to think
about and I think the main thing really
is it doesn't really fit with your
lifestyle so if you're at work all day
maybe you know a dog isn't isn't ideal
for you so no-nos thinks that she's got
his attention but I know how to get his
attention even more ed he's gonna be
gone can you have a little bit more sign
a little bit more I'd sign you a little
bit more because it's Christmas it's
Christmas and then that's enough
there you go oh yeah good boy the dogs
today we've we've generously had donated
lots of chicken and vegetables yeah
we're gonna be feeding the dogs a second
over there beginning a Christmas dinner
today fantastic that's pretty how many
you got in at the moment and we usually
have around at 450 right about 200 cats
so then okay I guess to have any more
okay no maybe one little bit more than
that's enough good boy good boy
thank you so much for bringing thank you
coming in it but you're not interested
in me anymore don't get any more food
ever you know back to Naz